this is the milk crate challenge the
goal to make it from one side of the
pyramid to the other
oh this is this is gone this is gone so
the problem here isn't that it's a
staircase or a pyramid but that these
are essentially individual columns of
crates
stacked on top of each other and they're
not just any columns they are totally
unsupported columns
my name is dr nehemiah mabry i'm a
professional engineer and i'm an
educator
columns are vertical slender members we
design them against a failure known as
buckling and basically it's a sudden
horizontal movement you can think of
maybe a a soda can if you step on a soda
can a lot of times it just kind of
collapses on itself um a ruler press on
the ends of the ruler you'll get a bend
sideways and it happens whenever the
force
exceeds what we call the critical load
critical low is the maximum amount of
weight or low that a column can take
before it becomes unstable
the skinnier and the taller a column is
the less of a critical load is needed
for it to get unstable
as you're walking up this crate
challenge you are literally getting to a
point to where what it takes for that
column to fail becomes less and less
you know what tops easiest going down is
going to be
so why is it here at the top of the
pyramid where most people tend to fall
off
sideways and see there it is
when you put it down
if you imagine that this is a column
there are different ways that the column
can be fixed right it can be embedded in
the ground which we call fixed it can't
move sideways nor can it rotate because
it's embedded in the ground and if we
have that same type of connection up
here this is your most stable column
right it's called fixed fix most
unstable column is when you have
something fixed or pin here and
literally there's no
there's no support up here
so that means that whatever load that
comes up here is basically going to have
to support itself and if this doesn't
have the stability that it needs then
you're going to get the buckling very
easily going up
you know you basically can rest your
weight
right but when you're stepping down you
actually have to control the placement
of your weight a little bit more than
you had to going up
and when it comes to
columns the placement of your weight
really really matters ideally in a
perfect case scenario a person will be
able to set their weight right down the
center of the crate and it literally has
what we call pure compression so that's
all that it's experiencing but really
if you happen to put your weight off to
the side now you're creating like a
rotational moment well the problem is
because these are separate crates it's
not like there's a continuation of the
of the member of the column to actually
push off of you're really depending on
your own muscle control to try to get it
back stable
which is extremely tough
so there are a couple of ways that if i
just had to build this and make it
structurally sound um i would find a way
to attach
each crate to each other with adhesive
or something to make it act as one
unified column another thing i would do
is create lateral support i would
probably have several rows of crates so
that when one begins to sway it can
distribute the load to another
i have just been able to explain to you
exactly why these things fail
but it's a totally different thing from
understanding it
and actually getting out there and doing
it it doesn't always translate
so even though i can very very clearly
explain to you what's going on here
you're still not gonna catch me doing
this crate challenge
and uh that should tell you something